let's start now with some of the kind of
last gasps of obvious 2020 election
delusion i'm going to talk to you about
the term decertification now some of you
will already know where this is going um
in the united states
once states
certify
an election
there is no legal provision to then
decertify that election
um and even if a state
figured out some way to decertify an
election if arizona now said hey we're
decertifying our election from november
of 2022
um it still wouldn't remove the sitting
president of the united states you'd
need to remove the sitting president you
know either through invoking the 25th
amendment and the process that goes
there or through impeachment and even if
you did that the vice president would
assume the position
so there is no such thing as
decertification
in the way that some people have been
claiming it exists
my pillow ceo mike lindell
known to us as mike pillow
he is still talking about election
decertification and in fact he appeared
yesterday on the stephen bannon show
called the war room uh stephen bannon is
a former trump adviser former breitbart
propagandist and he has been hosting
pillow for a while now and pillow's new
thing is he now has elected officials
supporting
multiple decertifications
it's happening imminently guys
imminently this is going to happen take
a look at this and ask yourself the
question
does pillow believe this
or is he just giving fodder to the last
people that still believe this stuff
well arizona you know that was a god
what about over a week ago now they uh
they've got quite a few representatives
and um uh senators that signed on we're
getting more and more every day i was in
wisconsin and all they need there we i
was over there with a great tim rampan a
uh he is the senator that put the bill
before to uh has it ready to decertify
wisconsin
no he doesn't pillow it was an amazing
event i was there for five hours i
planned on being there for a half hour
but there was wisconsin there all over
wisconsin but the lies were so
compelling he stayed five hours to go
hey we have the evidence let's get this
de-certified i met some other senators
and representatives steve they're
they're this close to getting on board
though
i believe we can get them all to jump on
together because a lot of them still
live in fear they're going you know fear
or they're not they were very
very um a lot of ed kids just to be
educated on this that a lot of them said
well there's nothing that can be done
anyway absolutely there can be done that
we've had lawyers constitutional lawyers
look at this three of these states you
you decertify and then it goes back to
all the states and uh and it votes one
person or one state one vote and it's
it's republican control that is a
complete and total lie i mean understand
that this is not aside from whether
there's the willingness to do this aside
from whether there's the interest of
doing this aside from whether there's
any empirical evidentiary support
put all of that aside even if it
happened it doesn't go back to where
each state gets to cast one vote about
who becomes president of the united
states it's just it's a fantasy so this
is very real and it's come it's
manifesting no it's coming to fruition
and it's gonna happen steve now
understand that pillow has made an
entire sequence of predictions in
november of 2020 he said by december it
would be flipped to trump in december he
said that in time for january 6 it would
be flipped to trump on january 7th or
8th he said by the time of the
inauguration it will be flipped to trump
after that he said march april then it
got pushed to the summer then the end of
summer then in august he said it would
be by october and then he said it's
going to be by thanksgiving and then
it's going to be by the end of the year
and
it's 2022 guys and it's not happening
now
we are
almost at the next election we're almost
at the midterms
everything that he says in this clip
about what could happen and how things
would happen is a lie i don't know
whether pillow even believes this stuff
i highly doubt bannon believes this
stuff
and the idea here is wisconsin
and arizona will decertify
the winds of joe biden
15 16 months ago
now to take it seriously for a second
this has been studied
there is no legal basis to decertify
a u.s presidential election
there is no provision in the
constitution to decertify a presidential
election to remove a sitting president
you need
they die okay then goes to the vp
um you have a the invocation of the 25th
amendment
if a president is unable to discharge
the powers of office you have a
conviction on impeachment you have a
resignation okay in all of these
situations the vice president becomes
the president you don't go
to a candidate who lost 15 months ago
constitutional experts have talked about
we've now talked about the electoral
count act many times
and it provides the process for
certifying the presidential election it
doesn't have a provision for
decertification and it's almost like
these guys like pillow and others think
anything any process that exists can be
run in reverse it's almost like hitting
a rewind button on a vcr
um it's not true
and even if a state were to undo its
certification
it would have no legal significance
whatsoever so these these people are in
a fantasy world i don't know whether
they believe it maybe you have some kind
of sense
as someone who watches youtube you know
how annoying it is to watch ads at the
beginning of videos that are completely
irrelevant to the content you're
watching that's why you always click the
skip add button our sponsor thought
leaders has just launched a new
targeting tool that allows advertisers
to choose the precise videos where their
ads will appear using the advanced
search in the thought leaders platform
which is powered by ai you can actually
find youtube videos relevant to your
brand's messaging and with thought
leaders precision targeting you can
really make every view count optimize
your ad spend
improve your conversions when brands put
their ads on relevant videos they catch
their audience when they are most
receptive and create a more fulfilling
enjoyable youtube experience for
everyone involved plans start at just
sixty dollars a month but you can try it
now for just thirty dollars for the
first month when you click the link
below and use the code pacman at
checkout